what's up reject nation we're gonna
watch a video today from supernatural
conventions our friend ash aided by our
other patron toasted toad SPN cast love
skittles and scars we love these
compilations that are put together thank
you so much for sending this to us in
advance over at our patreon we have a
weekly Q&A podcast formulated by your
guys's questions so thank you guys
but the biggest draw of our patreon
would definitely be our TV show
reactions over there we do watch alongs
and there are many shows where we have
the option for reaction highlights
included at the same tier and those
shows are as you'd expect Supernatural
Doctor Who JoJo's Bizarre Adventure the
promised Neverland attack on titan death
note my hero academia the two heroes
movie included Code Geass Hunter hunter
one punch man Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and there are shows where we
only have the watch a long option for
them shows like agents of shield Gotham
and there's a whole bunch of other ones
as well anywho head on over our patreon
today if you'd like to watch the
supernatural with us some Oh much about
the shoes too
[Music]
find fun what was your favorite season
to record
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh dear I know actually I do like for
quite a bit there's a strong because you
met somebody who wrangled you in
something totally impromptu I'm going to
look to my left and ask what my
partner's favorite part was or first
thing to come to mind of each season one
through ten season one what's the first
thing that comes to your mind look
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all this stage ran on the bed of the
seat where I had to say you had to hold
your breath and I took as long as I want
to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I was like I thought that was give it up
to everybody you know it you completely
outshine me in that scene so you know
and like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you see Jared
oh no way and then the second the second
memory was we shot the car laughing
afterwards
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so all the way back from said I had
wrapped late it was probably maybe eight
or nine o'clock some was that was night
I needed a charger for my phone because
I'd lost mine so on the way home from
set swung by a little electronics store
out and Burnaby I think somewhere
somewhere not close to town and just
this little tiny like even smaller than
a Radio Shack and I called a hand up I
heard you guys have a charger come on in
like alright so I open up open up a
little store doors in like a strip mall
and there's a desk and it's just kind of
an old electronic store they got old
monitors and stuff like that it and
there's one first behind the counter and
I walk up and I'm like hey and the
person just stares to be like blankly
and I'm like I called just a second ago
about the phone charger it's just like
oh my god and I go what
turn around and I turned around and
sitting on some some computer boxes was
a big giant piece of cardboard probably
like maybe like four feet by four feet
with a perfect rendition of my face made
out of skittles
here's a picture of a picture with it
well I took a picture of it yeah I will
find it I will find it the beginning of
a horror movie it was her co-worker
who happened to be off that night so the
phone immediately and I was like hi I'm
staring at a very odd picture of myself
then it was just like streams on the
other this is all because this person
was participating and Misha's scavenger
hunt and I guess at work decided to make
a portrait of me out of Skittles and who
I mean it was you're dead you got the
dimensions right it was four by four I
was stipulated it's got a picture of it
is that it oh yeah that's pretty
don't correct me imagine at night by
yourself walking into a very dark store
like one lone person terrifying and it's
just not amazing and then me right now
I'm gonna catch me because he look like
you but you also looks like a chimpanzee
I do have to say that that day that
wanted that horrible day it got it was
sort of thing he was he was such a would
be most that and it got so fun that
everybody started to join in so much so
than our be camera operator Brian Rose
had the camera on his shoulder was
filming Misha I was standing directly
next to him and Brian in the middle of
the tape just decided to just take his
shorts on
[Laughter]
and Greece is like you rides like that
was the day that people drove over from
the production offices to watch me
should do came on and and that's that's
what I was like okay this maybe was
given we don't know I could party that
day was when we turned around and the
camera was on you guys I was like I'm
gonna I'm gonna get them I'm doing to
make a paper airplane amazing plan of
revenge I mean you really you really
knocked it out of the park or that I
really did
really it is your boy you developing
[Music]
literally looks away at the most
inopportune times in the middle of a
scene he's just it's his turn to talk
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah it is interesting because as actors
we make choices before the character
early on in the in the process there
there are some things that we do that we
don't necessarily we're not really aware
that we're going to be married to here's
a here's an example for deed in season 1
there were we went to talk to somebody
about something like Sam and Dean do to
get information about a case and there
happened to be some hors d'oeuvres on
the table that this person decided to
lead there it wasn't written in the
script it was a directive things like
you know maybe put something like you
know crackers and cocktail sausages and
things I was able well I just was like
you know Buster was like yeah they
weren't meant to be eaten it's okay they
were fresh but they weren't meant to be
like well I'm sorry do you have another
bag because I'm just an adopter and a
doctor now gonna be so anyway yes there
are because we make we make kind of
decisions of choices you can spur the
woman he's more mature with the goatee
there's no sentiment in sauces character
gentleman series is the actor does
things and the writers watch this and
then they start writing towards what the
actor is doing and they start it so it's
a collaboration as the character
develops so I'm sure that there are
things that Misha is like man why did I
do the voice thing
in me as well you know to starring your
face in real life then what do you mean
I can't speak then we have an entire
visual effects Department
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you know who is very supportive
asperities to do alright oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so as I was waiting for my taxi show up
there was a little flinch where there
was like a planner just rolling along so
it was a little higher than I
anticipated
and I just hit you no way you gotta be
kidding just look at me yeah possible
after God so holy when I was working I
hit the next day off I'm just holding my
chin together like I don't think it's
broken I'm pretty sure the camera is not
gonna let me into his cab so I was like
apologizing the visual effects
Department now has to the tracking marks
in my face remove the it was a nice suit
nice change
nice defined check so but the the part
about it was the person that had taken
me out was the previous head of the
visual effects Department having to fix
but anyway if the network cream doesn't
work take out the stars we always know
the visual effects Department [ __ ] marry
kill the cast of supernatural now I
wasn't before but I'm going to have to
deflation
as a matter of fact I do not
at Mary Jensen really kill Misha and I
think we know where that leaves us
[Applause]
because anything a good shower oh forget
about it
hey thank you dude oh he's always warm
my heart so much beginning of a month
it's like a thing I look forward to from
a soul I mean we earned it yeah yeah
we've been working hard in terms of fmk
it's pretty simple what I would do guys
honestly my answer as much as I love me
some Stephen Amell
I got a disagree up pretty much every
choice yeah like my answers came to me
like like that I'm married Misha I would
- Misha I mean if it's based off the
Convention footage
Misha seemed like the marriage material
like the one you want spend your life
with I've f Jared yes I definitely F
Jared coz yeah you turn him over the
long hair imagine a woman that's just a
joke let's go with the guy thing and
then I'd kill Jensen but but I would
keep his body safe and I would preserve
it encrusted in skittles that's the one
thing I would really love would Jensen's
dead Buffy this and I would slowly after
preserving eat him a little by little
over time you've been watching Hannibal
as early as dinner - both Misha
and whenever we include Jared in the
bedroom and the habit it is everybody
good to know that they're eating Jensen
Oh that'd be the captain
any idea but I'm gonna fmk okay so yeah
yeah marry Misha but I think I I think I
would kill Jared and keep Jared's body
around because I feel like everybody you
know he's got the locks he is the one
that seems like even though Dean plays
the ladies man he seems like you know
Jared's the one who people fawn over in
public so I feel like I could probably
charge people to come visit his body if
I were to preserve it plus you know then
I get Jensen who seems like a chill guy
and him ameesha me yeah like we could
get that three-way action going on you
know still j2m cuz I'm John despite the
fact that Jared a few months ago was
arrested for public intoxication and
getting some bar brawls I still get the
impression Jensen's the one when not
drunk is probably the one with a little
bit more of a temper in terms of
devouring the human body more muscle
jared is taller so but I'm cocky you get
better meat okay that's how I play fmk
guys I decide yeah this is a fun one the
season two did it happen we're only on
season five right now and as they were
asking this I was thinking I remembered
thinking the show got way better around
season two I remember the first episode
of season two it's so in with John
Winchester when he dies but what the
hell happened to it like even for myself
oh yeah season five going wait I really
remember season three for what happened
in season two again
sterling K Brown Oh Bonnie remarkable of
season two I can imagine for them like
this this is a giant mumbo jumbo of
memories here you know what and you know
you think you spend long days and I'm
sure that there's you know not when
you're in production all the sleep in
the world so to that effects the way you
keep these memories and yeah shooting so
many getting on the routine I have to
imagine that
a certain point word associating a
specific season is probably easier for
fans than the people who made the show
yeah it all bleeds together dude Jared's
with the quick answers of how he met his
wife Genevieve such a hottie such a
hottie I can't tell who's hotter vivre
or Jared comment below so far we haven't
seen any convention footage with her
there I feel like she would be of us I
got to that point where they're like
well now that we're like married let's
not be doing like conventions and stuff
together you know that way we can
maintain some sense of privacy since
people know we met on I can see that
conversation happening or maybe they
don't want people stepping up to the mic
like role plays the characters but it
would Rama believe it would be a mutual
way to unwind especially after some long
shoot days I love this notion that Jared
was harassing her yeah tailing her
around was what did somebody was like
boyishly charming can you boyishly
charmingly keep following a girl anymore
that's the trouble with romantic
gestures and romantic fixations is that
I think the thin line depends entirely
on perspective I feel I got two
takeaways on these topics I've been very
different than what people were hoping
for today one thing I noticed this is an
actual thing I noticed the progression
that these convention footage
compilations have taken us on because
the further we get into the show the
more things get revealed and more people
you're sorry to see pop up because I've
heard them say like Richard Speight or
Spade however you say it this way Eddie
Richard spaghetti place Gabriel the
trickster he's apparently like yeah he
does DMC bit a lot like he often does
hosting for these like he's a part of it
you see the guy who plays Chuck is in a
few of these he's even sometimes up
playing music with Jensen it's cool to
see the family of the show growing and
also people like aja Tyler Stephen Amell
popping up or even the guy who was
Crowley just seeing him there - it's
cool to see the family grow and I hope
that maybe as some of those guys become
more fixed in the supernatural
conventions we'll start seeing more
stories pop up from them as well yeah as
you know
as Misha became mark and grained into
the show sure enough we start seeing
more stories and bits with hymns I mean
the fact that Matt Cohen was there is
young John Winchester had me thinking
are we gonna see more of young John
Winchester's there's only that one
episode I remember the one that was like
kind of starting off like a tribute sit
back to the future and it takes some
turns where's oh it was the mom who's
actually the honor what's funny about
this is I loved his story was my
favorite parts of this whole compilation
I barely remembered any of his lines or
specific scenes in that episode like I
remember him being there but I don't
remember much I remember the flavor that
he really made an impression here this
game yeah was he talking about Jenna's
lips - yeah I pointed that out like I'm
watching the show I'm like is he wearing
like sand really shiny chapstick or
something their episodes were his lips
just really dude shine and he's got the
lips of an angel man no I believe you is
that episode actually when I first
noticed it get so much of it was in
broad daylight we should go back and
revisit come to the patreon in fact
check yeah that's that I'm so glad he
pointed that out this is the height
thing about them seems to be a
reoccurring topic of people are always
taken aback by when you meet them and I
agree with Richards
they call him Richard Dickey the rest of
the joke that's how I agree with that
assessment about you know when you see
people on television you assume they're
hiding and they're always taller in real
life miss Vaughn is a tall guy I saw him
in person
Wow guys really tall Jared and Jensen
don't look that tall especially when
they're together you stop thinking about
it yeah I could see Jared being fairly
tall like taller than us but the way
everyone describes him is they're really
really tall and I think that detail
helps to drive at home like what luck
that we found the two leads who are
super tall and the short one is 6 1 yeah
because yeah that immediately just in
grains it as a thing yeah absolutely
these actor choices I love I love
stories about when they dive into their
their craft and what help formulate
their a character because yeah there's a
common
shamrock it's a reoccurring thing about
Dean as he's always munch and he's like
rusty from oceans alive he's always
eating him food and I think I remember
that moment don't what he's talking
about so long ago but I actually think I
recall there had a vague image in my
head of that bit yeah and then it did
become that then I've pointed that out
so many times when watching the show of
like how does he Steve it didn't eat so
much and all the time it seems there's
no regard for what he's eating and they
never do like a thing where they're
taking a break for them to like exercise
or weightlifter something you know I
want the episode season six better have
an episode where they're taking naps
they're working out realistically stage
shape well maybe that's because they
only eat once a day yeah and so he's
like well I got to get my carbs so beer
it's like drinking bread and right you
know have burgers or something load up
on proteins I love this story about the
scars oh yeah that sounds god-awful
horrible but I love that notion of he's
injured this is my fault no one pushed
me I I did a small thing that should
have been nothing and and yet here we
are nothing that happened in Canada
though get some free health care out of
that you do that see bill change for a
couple months even that bill will put a
dent in that man's pocket but I can't
imagine seem like things like that cuz
like I love the the conversation about
the actor choices because that
highlights ya the collaborative nature
of like there are people noticing your
performance and going oh cool work with
that but then on the completely opposite
side I have to imagine that a lot of
shows they get to go a certain length of
time or even movies that shoot for a
certain length of time probably have a
few of those stories where it's like oh
man somebody injured themselves in a
weird way we gotta fix this yeah oh yeah
tearing production happens a lot hell
that even happen with Luke Skywalker
from a new hope to Empire you guys ain't
cut off real life
not the same exact thing they did have
to you know postpone workaround right
yeah but not her many stories like that
happening and also with the performance
partner okay I just love how me show is
like the things I don't like and I feel
like I'm kind of responsible like you're
already like fully responsible you like
you chose the voice didn't like the
hunching mannerisms
yeah bad I'm like someone brought that
to the tables that every bride imagine
right well and that was funny too
because even Jensen like when you can
tell in his regular speaking voice even
he has to pitch his voice down you know
significant yeah Castiel is a little bit
I gotta talk to you down here yeah I
gotta go down the bottom of my vocal
range so that half of what I say is just
wheezing he does yeah and he does do
that thing where he's like usually
looking around and he can see I'm a guy
I imagine everything it's kind of like
the matrix yeah yeah yeah he's way more
dimensions than you could fathom yeah
he's looking through time and space
right now oh this is great Thank You ash
Thank You toasted for whatever part of
this you contributed to guys subscribers
supernatural conventions you can check
us out on patreon today click that
notification bell please hit the like
button on this video helps the algorithm
out a lot if you made it this far
well you're in luck because we got a
Anissa a liver home girl I have no clue
where to begin with how to forgive
genuine thanks to you there are a
gazillion different avenues I could go
down you like protect us weird thing to
say but you are like a guardian angel
you fight for honor
you are our Castiel you yeah you're our
chivalrous Knight whoa Sam indeed our
Castiel was we reboot it with a female
yes yes
which one of us gets to be Sam and Dean
though because one of us is gonna have a
much better relationship than you okay
Museum what the hell's wrong with you
okay that's right that means being an
anything we're not gonna get along so
good oh we're not changing the show man
you're gonna end up in a romantic
relationship with a gay hookup with
Robby
[Laughter]
I don't play by era of course they do
there I meet Erica denisa would be a
perfect pairing they are like our
warriors of Honor yeah and these guys
there's no way to put it you're a
guardian angel or the caste of the
female call of you know until we catch
up with some other word male character
the show you do ovie the female
character in the show he's not dying or
revealed themselves to be a demon or
been a demon from the story yeah Pam
love you dear there's no really no it's
bottomless pit of words that I could
find himself they love